apenas había aterrizado y ya estaba
trabajando en las relaciones
diplomáticas Franco africanas el
presidente de Francia Emanuel macron
inició el miércoles una gira de cuatro
días por África Central para promover lo
que denominó como una nueva relación
mutua y responsable con las antiguas
colonias europeas comenzando en gabón el
jefe de estado asiste a la Cumbre One
Forest una reunión internacional sobre
la preservación de los bosques
tropicales pero para algunos Esta visita
no es bienvenida consideran que el
momento elegido para el viaje sirve para
dar un impulso político al presidente
alibongo de Cara a las próximas
elecciones generales de este año
tenemos la impresión de que existe un
tipo de hipocresía en torno a esta
cuestión climática
se utiliza como truco para apoyar una
dictadura porque el régimen gabonés se
considera una dictadura y creemos que
Francia con la llegada de macron agavon
no hace más que apoyar la dictadura de
Bongo
los jaboneses deben saber defenderse de
la doble opresión Es decir de Francia y
luego del clambón
si no somos capaces de defendernos si
nos pasamos el tiempo quejándonos y
lloriqueando no conseguiremos salir de
esta doble opresión
y tú acusaciones que el Eliseo ha
denunciado el lunes el presidente macron
reveló su estrategia para África en los
próximos años en un intento de
distanciarse del pasado colonial de
Francia y de contrarrestar las
crecientes influencias de China y de
Rusia en la región en los últimos meses
el ejército francés se ha visto obligado
a abandonar mal y burkina faso tras
diferencias con las nuevas autoridades
militares de los países
después de gabón Emmanuel macron viajará
a Angola Congo y terminará su gira en
República democrática del Congo donde el
miércoles los residentes se manifestaron
frente a la embajada francesa en contra
de la llegada del jefe de estado